the khan academy now has about 20
something thousand subscribers on
youtube this is as of mid-october 2009
and about 60 000 unique users a month if
my web blogs are right i think it's lame
that we have no way to interact with
each other so i finally joined facebook
i think i'm probably the last person on
the planet to do it but i did it so that
we can create a little world for the
khan academy so just go to khan
academy.org
and up here you'll see this little link
for the khan academy facebook page just
click on that and you'll go to the khan
academy facebook page which i literally
just set up last night and the idea here
is for hopefully some subset of that 20
something thousand subscribers or 70 000
unique users to come on here and we'll
be able to interact with each other you
can let me know what type of videos
you'd like to see a lot of uh your just
general questions i'll try to actively
answer on this message board and then
they'll be here for other people with
with similar questions and what i'm
really hoping is that you guys can start
to essentially help each other right now
it's kind of just you know i'm putting
up videos and you all are watching the
videos and hopefully you're finding them
useful but sometimes on the youtube
videos we actually have some pretty neat
discussions where you guys are answering
each other's questions and i thought
that this would be a really neat
environment for that because clearly
everyone who is a regular user of the
khan academy is interested in learning
and improving themselves and i think
they'll all benefit from interactions
with each other so come to this this
facebook i don't know what it's even
called what's it called a facebook page
it's public anyone can join it and and
and then the side effect actually is
obviously we'll all benefit if we can
interact with each other and i can give
you all regular updates what's going on
on my end and you all can let me know
what you'd like to see me do more of and
then the other benefit would be you can
kind of do all of these things that
facebook has on you can become a fan of
this page and then this will help
broaden the awareness of the khan
academy because i think if you found it
helpful it'll probably be helpful for
millions of other people and the more
people that know about it the more
resources that hopefully we'll have to
keep making videos and eventually
software and and who knows what else so
just come here and and hopefully you
know uh this this little this little
khan academy page on facebook will be
somewhat useful